it's time for series four of our SGC fan
fiction and this week it's a goodie it's
an ancient prequel and we're gonna get
to find out all about the feelings
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so so far in our new series this SGC
idea that we had a few weeks ago we have
described what would happen in series
one where we will meet all of the
characters from Stargate command the
core of this show that everything else
will hang off we will meet lots of those
characters we'll find out where the
Stargate is we'll find out in our
version at least that Daniel Jackson is
now the civilian leader of the SGC and
that hopefully a few other characters
are returned as well in the second
series we wandered off to Destiny and
we've got to bring Eli home in the third
series we got to see Atlantis again and
the furling stole the ancient city and
took it to a zpm factory they knew don't
worry McKay and Shepard saved the day
now it's time for series four and in
this idea again it would start in and
around the SGC we would see those
characters but then it would revert to a
prequel now if you are a regular
Sidetrack you'll know I hate prequels I
think they're crap I think they peel
over Cannon generally and I don't want
anything to do them all the Star Trek
ones even strange new worlds to be
honest annoy me Strange New World set in
like a post TNG era I'd love that but
remaking the original series kind of
irritates me but in this I think it's
actually a prequel that could work for
one it would be set at least 10 000
years before everything that happened in
Stargate it would actually add to the
story and the Canon rather than taken
away and as long as they did it
carefully it doesn't need to pee on
Canon but what would happen in this
series well as you know the feelings are
not evil Ewoks we don't actually know
anything about them that whole scene
where we see the little Ewoks is just
what was imagined in O'Neill's head
so we don't know now we get to see them
at the start of this series
they walk through the gate but initially
they appear like almost like a
ghost-like figure and then they form
into a human figure but my idea is that
through this series we'd get to see that
actually a shape-shifting type of being
and that you don't really ever find out
what they really look like don't forget
that if you enjoy the content you can
hit the join button and become a fully
fledged side tracker that really helps
out the channel you can go to
cygashtrack.com there's loads of like
merchandise things on there and a load
of new designs coming very soon also if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to like subscribe and hit the Bell
notification so you miss none of our new
videos as well as the Sidetrack sides
channels now the one thing we do know
about the feelings is that they are
pacifists and they were one of the great
four original races
we also know that they were Allied
against the gold the other thing that we
know is that at some point the goal wall
did attack some failings they set up a
utopian society for all species to come
and live in safety and peace but the
gold all through in some suicide plants
and everybody killed each other but
other than that we don't know really
anything about them so they are kind of
a blank slate we could do whatever we
want so the point of the fourth season
would be to see the furlings and to get
to know them a little bit more now I
have to say that this storyline was
actually inspired by a subscriber who
gave me permission to steal his idea but
I've added to it and changed it a little
bit so in this storyline the furlings
actually created the gold now there are
two possibilities on why they could have
done that it could have been a genetic
experiment um designed to actually
increase their own life cycle and
because as we know the the gold live a
very long time you know maybe they came
across the snake heads on a planet and
they genetically manipulated them
um in an idea of trying to create a new
species a symbiont that would actually
enhance and increase their own lifespan
or perhaps they were genetically
modified to behave as a teacher for
Humanity now I quite like this idea
um if you think about the genetic memory
of the gold walls that could be
something that could be programmed in
but also I'm wondering whether the
furlings wanted to almost act like
parents to humanity but felt that we
needed teachers a race to guide us maybe
they knew by this point that they were
beginning to ascend and that the
Ancients were beginning to ascend
because I think this would be around 10
or 15 000 years ago so perhaps as I say
they knew that the great races were
starting to leave and they wanted to
leave behind a parent figure to help us
grow
but my idea is that then a sect of this
furling race actually felt that Humanity
was growing too quickly and instead of a
father figure we needed a master so the
gold were altered or at least most of
them were this could also explain maybe
why the tokra are completely different
so they were changed and manipulated to
become the beings the bad guys we then
get to deal with for the next 10 000
years now when the remaining ancients
the the rest of the feelings and the
Asgard discover this portrayal they
don't know what to do about it they
can't Wipe Out the gold because that
would be genocide and go against
everything they believe in particularly
the pacifist feelings so the sect that
created this problem were banished the
asgardo put in charge of policing the
remaining gold and humanity and the
remaining furlings
stayed behind to watch creating things
like the utopian Planet a safe haven for
people but the Gold World attacked
so the feelings that were remained
either ascended left our galaxy never to
return or were actually murdered by
their own creation but where did the
furlings get banished too now I've got a
couple of ideas for this they could have
just been kicked out of the Galaxy
obviously that's a simple one but maybe
the Stargate was used as some sort of
prison I was thinking like a Star Trek
sort of thing you know sometimes they
use the transporter as um like a holding
pattern so they put you in the buffers
and you just stay there and it happened
to Scotty in a TNG episode and then he
materialized that 30 years later
maybe there's a Stargate somewhere
that's a similar type of thing that
instead of it traveling from one point
to another that they are being held in
some sort of stasis or that the
stargate's been used to take the
furlings to like a parallel universe or
something along those lines maybe you
know the mirror from that one episode
has been used to put them in a parallel
universe now while the Asgard was still
here policing our galaxy and the gold
the fillings that were banished could
never return but now the Asgard are gone
so for some reason somehow 10 or 15
years after we lost the Asgard the
furlings have been able to escape their
prison and have returned
this would be the whole setup for the
fourth season and this would also
leading to why now the furlings are at
least our enemy it's not necessarily
because they want to kill us it's not
because they're evil it's because they
know we reproduce like crazy and we're a
virus and wherever we go I'm thinking
agent Smith style here you know let's be
honest let's look at what we're doing to
our own Planet I can understand that a
peaceful pacifist race would look at
that and consider us a blight on this
world maybe this is a Thanos type of
thing where they realize they need to
cut our numbers for our own safety and
at the end of the day the policing
measure that they put in they go award
are now gone because we killed them so
moving forward in the rest of the season
the furlings are going to try to control
our numbers again they are going to look
at our technological advancements
particularly the Towery very fearfully
so what will they do in the future
seasons
you're gonna have to hold on and find
out because I will tell you very shortly
but for now get in the comments tell me
what you think about this story idea and
more importantly tell me how you think
we could move forwards with this
storyline in the next couple of Seasons
I can't wait to hear all of your
brilliant ideas as usual
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you are enjoying the content and you
want to support the Channel please hit
the join button because that really
helps us out as always guys please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]